das corona virus befällt zwar die lunge
verursacht aber schon jetzt ein flaues
gefühl im magen
eine epidemie kurz vor dem ausbruch wie
der bundesgesundheitsminister befürchtet
und ein virus über dessen
ausbreitungsgeschwindigkeit wir noch zu
wenig wissen
das gebot der stunde ist aufklärung
prävention und umsicht das gegenteil
davon wären angst und panik krone in
deutschland wie gefährlich ist das virus
jetzt in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
damen und herren nach dem auftreten der
fälle von corona infektionen in europa
und in deutschland hat sich die lage
deutlich verschärft wir haben deshalb
den auftrag als verantwortliche minister
das menschenmögliche zu tun
zum schutz unserer bevölkerung ohne dass
wir den absoluten schutz versprechen
können den es natürlich nie gibt in
diesem fall soweit der
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer der
heute gemeinsam mit dem
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
diese pressekonferenz zum choriner virus
veranstaltet hat in der
bundespressekonferenz herzlich
willkommen wie die zuschauer bei uns
meine gäste hier im studio ist brigitte
fehrle ist bei uns freie journalistin
und kolumnistin professor jonas
schmidt-chanasit ist bei uns virologe an
der universität in hamburg und auch
tätig am bernhard-nocht-institut für
tropenmedizin ebenfalls in der
hansestadt
volker treier ist stellvertretender
hauptgeschäftsführer des deutschen
industrie und handelskammertags und dort
zuständig für außenwirtschaft und
professor heiner fangerau ist
medizinhistoriker an der universität in
düsseldorf
herr schmidt chanasit sprechen beim
corona virus von einer stehen pandemie
das kommt mir irgendwie nicht richtig
vertrauenserweckend ja ist es auch nicht
weil sich das virus eben unbemerkt
weltweit verbreitet hat das können wir
jetzt so sagen es ist ja auf allen
kontinenten angekommen und das ist genau
das problematisch ist zu spät erkannt
dass es angekommen sondern kann man auch
erst verspätet gegenmaßnahmen ergreifen
die in italien und das führt dazu dass
wir es eben jetzt weltweit mit
ausbrüchen zu tun haben das ist
natürlich eine pandemie anfang an es
heißt immer keine panik das ist leichter
gesagt als getan
wie groß ist denn die gefahr dass panik
die bekämpfung dieses corona virus noch
erheblich erschwert wir wissen aus der
geschichte wie mit solchen umgegangen
wird und oft ist es so dass die erste
reaktion ist alles im griff keine panik
und schon die zweite und dritte reaktion
sind gott leute lauft und die panik
die dann ausbricht verschafft eigentlich
die situation dadurch dass andere güter
verschwinden
panikkäufe davon haben wir gehört
supermärkte wie leer sind medikamente
die anderswo gebraucht werden die
ausgehen oder krankenhäuser überfüllt
sind die fälle ist die gegenwärtige
reaktion der politik auf diese
epidemiegefahr ist die vertrauensbildend
ja und nein also wenn man sich heute die
pressekonferenz angeguckt hat von den
sparren und horst seehofer
so hatte ich das gefühl sie sind sehr
sehr bemüht um ruhe um balance um
zuversicht zu verbreiten aber die
maßnahmen die sind dann vorgestellt
haben hatte ich eher das gefühl die sind
dazu da die bevölkerung doch zu
beunruhigen
also insofern war das so eine
unausgegorene situation die man
vielleicht gar nicht vermeiden kann es
nur jenes nicht den vorwurf sein das
wäre glaube ich an der stelle hat euer
die börsen die zucken ja schon
bedenklich ist dass eine überreaktion
oder gibt es in der realwirtschaft
tatsächlich schon eine gefährliche
entwicklung
ich halte das nicht für eine
überreaktion sondern fast kann man sagen
dass die börsen jetzt erst so reagieren
heisst dass sie das was in china jetzt
auch wirtschaftlichen konsequenzen
festzustellen ist jetzt erst 10 nachdem
das virus auch mehr menschen in europa
erfasst hat und unsere unternehmen in
china wir haben über 5.000 deutsche
unternehmen in china die berichten nicht
erst seit ende des frühlingsfestes
anfang dieses monats sondern innerhalb
der letzten drei wochen dass die räder
und bänder sozusagen stillstehen was zu
anderen zeitpunkten einmal zu stärkeren
reaktionen auch an den börsen geführt
hätte herr schmidt schauen dass ich lass
es uns vielleicht noch mal auf den
aktuellen fall weil er vielleicht auch
ganz beispielhaft ist in nordrhein
westfalen eingehen dass er so eine art
klassiker der ausbreitung also wir haben
da einen 47 jährigen
der eine vorerkrankung hatte der jetzt
lebensgefährlich erkrankt ist künstlich
beatmet wird
seine ehefrau ist kindererzieherin also
die hat auch viel mit kindern zu tun die
waren beide im karneval unterwegs auf
eine keiner weise zum vorher noch im
ungewissen im urlaub in den niederlanden
wenn man das hört da kommen ja
eigentlich alle präventionsmaßnahmen zu
spät zumal ja jetzt im kreis heinsberg
glaube ich bis zu 400 leuten in
häuslicher quarantäne sind und heute
abend gab es noch mal 14 neu infektionen
mit corona virus da ist praktisch nichts
mehr zu machen da das irgendwie
einzudämmen dass dieses wort viele heute
offen in der pressekonferenz
sie sehen ja schon das ist eine sehr
dynamische situation das hatte auch der
minister noch einmal betont natürlich
helfen die maßnahmen das ganze zu
verlangsamen aber ich glaube keiner
glaubt mir ernsthaft daran und spricht
davon dass man das stoppen könnte
die enden findet man nicht mehr so zu
sagen wer deshalb als patient null das
hat man ja auch in italien gesehen
insofern wird man einige cluster
nachvollziehen können aber wie gesagt
letztendlich nicht alle patienten oder
die die sich infiziert haben
identifizieren können und das führt dazu
dass es sich immer weiter ausbreiten und
vielleicht noch etwas zur beruhigung zu
sagen dieser krankheitsverlaufs der
kennt ja drei stufen quasi an der
leichte verlauf etwa 80 prozent soweit
sie das wissen ein schwerer verlauf
etwas so 18 prozent und ein bis zwei
prozent verlaufen tödlich kann man das
so sagen damit ist es ja sag mal der
prozentsatz die wirkliche lebensgefahr
relativ gering
das muss man ganz klar und deutlich
sagen und zudem muss man auch noch mal
betonen diese daten haben wir aus china
dort war eine ausnahmesituationen
vorhang ein zusammenbruch des gesamten
medizinischen versorgungssystems und es
bleibt abzuwarten ob sich diese zahlen
auch in sozusagen sehr gut aufgestellten
ländern bestätigen
wenn wir nach korea gucken sieht es
anders aus dort haben wir deutlich unter
einem prozent sterblichkeit war jetzt
über knapp 2000 infizierten das ist das
genau was wir erreichen wollen eine gute
und schnelle behandlung der
risikopatienten und damit eine geringere
sterblichkeit als wir sie bisher sehen
wir reden ja immer von china als haben
jetzt auch dieses beispiel gerade
genannt jetzt sind aber noch andere
länder südkorea/japan auch der iran ist
ja ein wichtiger handelspartner im
moment natürlich durch diese aktionen
etwas geschwächt
das heißt es würde sich für die deutsche
wirtschaft ja noch aus ganz anderen
länder aus denen diese bedrohung
das ist das was ich meine wir beobachten
dass die wirtschaftliche reaktion gerade
auf die behördlichen maßnahmen in china
schon jetzt eine gewisse zeit
festzustellen sind wir sehen das gerade
südostasiatische aber auch ostasiatische
länder wie korea wie wie japan
deutlichere reisebeschränkungen
gegenüber china erhoben haben seit
wochen
daraus konnte man auch vermuten dass die
wirtschaftliche reaktion stärker sein
wird und in korea haben wir gesehen dass
die exporte nach china um 50 prozent
eingebrochen sind schon also und da
haben wir noch nicht darüber geredet
dass viele menschen dort infiziert sind
also wir haben es hier mit einer
größeren wirtschaftlichen
beeinträchtigung zu tun als dass man nur
so über eine kleine delle sprechen kann
was ja auch sie mit globalisierung und
globaler 500 kommen wir noch im laufe
der sendung darauf wie gut sind wir denn
vorbereitet sie haben ja gesagt in der
pressekonferenz so ein bisschen das
gefühl vielleicht ist an der einen oder
anderen stelle doch noch einiges unklar
wichtig sei immer wie sie es mit den
krankenhäusern aus wie viele
isolierstationen stehen zur verfügung
und unglaublich um die 14.000 betten in
deutschland oder 17.000 ist ging dafür
verschiedene zahlen heute durch die
durch die meldungen
wie muss man sich das vorstellen können
wir da wirklich was die vorbereitung
angeht einigermaßen sicher sein das
würde ja heute auch so gesagt also alle
die sich dazu heute geäußert haben und
auch in den letzten tagen dazu geäußert
haben haben konnten glaube ich
einigermaßen glaubwürdig darlegen dass
deutschland da gar nicht schlecht oder
relativ gut
relativ gut aufgestellt ist also der
gesundheitsminister hat heute auch wie
ich finde eine sehr gute figur abgegeben
wenn man das mal so sagen kann in dem
zusammenhang er hat sehr sehr
zurückhaltend sehr vorsichtig reagiert
und hat die einzelnen maßnahmen
vorgestellt und auch der
bundesinnenminister
ich glaube das problem liegt ein
bisschen im föderalismus in deutschland
weil eben die ganze versorgung auf
landesebene passiert und auch die
katastrophenpläne alle auf landesebene
organisiert sind
das scheint im moment noch kein problem
zu sein aber wenn es tatsächlich zu
einem größeren ausbruch kommt und so
schien mir das heute auch da noch unklar
zu bleiben dann hat ja der bund im
durchgriffsrecht aber wie das dann genau
stattfinden soll war auf so eine lage
ist man zwar theoretisch vorbereitet
aber sowas ist einfach praktisch
natürlich überhaupt noch nie ausprobiert
worden welchen einfluss hat denn solche
als solches auftreten von politikern in
der öffentlichkeit die ja dann den
menschen erklären sollen was er jetzt
vor sich geht was passieren könnte auch
die ganzen prävention sie die
vorsichtsmaßnahmen
gerade im hinblick auf panik und
hysterie irgendwann mal wird sie ein
medikament gegen korona virus geben aber
es gibt wahrscheinlich kein kraut
gewachsen gegen hysterie da wird es nie
ein medikament geben was welche rolle
spielen dass solche öffentlichen
auftritte gerade was so ganz persönliche
dinge angeht wie gesundheit die jeden
menschen wichtig ist die auftritte
sollen beruhigen auch die aussagen
sollen beruhigen und die zahlen selber
sind statistisch gedacht eher beruhigend
aber wenn ich selber vor der frage stehe
bin ich krank bin ich nicht krank werde
ich krank werde ich nicht krank dann
interessiert mich nicht ob ein prozent
der menschen daran verstört sondern ob
ich daran sterbe
und deshalb haben die politiker
ungeheuer schwere aufgabe auch die
politikerin zu argumentieren auf der
einen seite für ruhe und ordnung
und auf der anderen seite für maßnahmen
die dann und das ist auch nicht von der
hand zu weisen
angesichts einer bedrohungslage doch
eher banal wirken der rückgriff auf
klassische hygienemaßnahmen wie wir sie
seit 150 jahren mindestens kennen von
händewaschen
bis ja in ellenbogen schnäuzen das wirkt
mich beruhigend ja und vor allem steht
es in relativen widerspruch zum auftritt
der halben bundesregierung heute also
der gesundheitsminister der
innenminister der wirtschaftsminister
hat auch noch eine pressekonferenz heute
gegeben also man hat sozusagen von der
symbolwirkung hat man das gefühl höchste
alarmstufe aber das was dann praktisch
gesagt wird was an maßnahmen
vorgeschlagen wird ist dann eher wieder
wenig und also das war mein ungutes
gefühl was ich heute hatte dass diese
dinge nicht so richtig zusammenpassen
und das bei der bevölkerung auch als
unklarheit ankommen so allerdings wenn
sie sagen da gibt es ein subjektives
bedrohungsgefühl aber es gibt auch eine
objektive gefahr anlage
wir haben zurzeit etwa 100.000 an der
normalen influenza erkrankte infizierte
und wir haben immer mit 400 menschen in
häuslicher quarantäne stand heute abend
und ich glaube 46 infizierte jetzt ist
gerade sie fast jeder sendung über
dieses thema kommt man kommt er oder
kommt das gespräch auf die
hygienemaßnahmen händewaschen in die
armbeuge neu zu geht sonst noch wichtig
ist was man den menschen raten kann als
präventive maßnahme um möglichst eine
infektion zu vermeiden
nein das ja eine frage gewesen
die kollegin sozusagen was was man sich
da vielleicht erwartet hand haushalt
diesen maßnahmen die wenn sie im
umgesetzt werden von der vielzahl von
menschen auch wirklich wirksam sein
können um das ganze zu verlangsamen ich
glaube was man deutlich machen muss dass
und ich glaube das wurde auch deutlich
macht dass niemand erwarten kann
dass das jetzt gestoppt werden kann und
dass man sich eben nicht infiziert es
geht jetzt darum dass nur langsam und
die leute die mir ein höheres risiko für
schwere verläufe dass die schnell und
gut behandelt werden können welche
allgemeinen hygienemaßnahmen außer denen
die gerade schon professor fang genannt
hat genau also wir würden darauf hat
sich natürlich uns die hände zu geben in
der öffentlichkeit möglichst auch in der
öffentlichkeit gegenstände also tür
knöpfer unsere der türklinken eben nicht
anzufassen häufiges händewaschen der
händedesinfektion wenn man eben nicht
händewaschen kann man sich eben von
kranken fernhalten und was auch eine
sehr wirksame maßnahme ist die sich auch
ohne große schädigung natürlich
durchsetzen lässt entsprechende
massenveranstaltung wir haben die db in
berlin geplant also das sind maßnahmen
die man durchaus denke ich auch
durchsetzen kann es ist eine nationale
tourismus börse die ja jetzt
möglicherweise abgesagt wird also keine
fussballspiele kein rockkonzert der im
moment das sind da sind ganz klar
sozusagen ereignisse wo es zu sehr
vielen übertragung kommen kann
aber wir müssen immer im hinterkopf
haben und das ist glaube ich dann eben
auch für die politik zu entscheiden wir
dürfen die infrastruktur nicht so stark
einschränken und schwächen das eben eine
versorgung eine gute schnelle versorgung
der kranken nicht mehr möglich ist
jetzt ist er manchmal der angst um die
gesundheit macht mir ja genau das
falsche
wer sich möglicherweise diese symptome
einer krone erkrankung hat also husten
glaube ich fiebere und vor allem soll
eine allgemeine übelkeit und ein
allgemeines sollte möglichst nicht zum
arzt gehen denn dann kann er erst recht
dort andere noch anstecken oder wenn man
hingeht und hat nichts könnte man von
jemand anders abgesteckt werden
ich glaube in kinderarztpraxen werden
bis zu 150 kinder pro tag gebracht
mit symptome die oft an damit gar nichts
zu tun haben das ja auch so eine art
panikreaktion die leute machen sich
sorgen und man muss jetzt eben ganz klar
sagen wie sie damit umgehen sollen und
man muss sagen wir kommen sicherlich in
das stadion wenn es 1000 oder eben
10.000 erkranken gibt wo eben der
schnupfen keine rolle mehr spielt ob das
kroner ist oder eben nicht dann geht es
um das um die risikogruppen sozusagen
die behandelt werden müssen
ältere patienten mit vorerkrankungen an
dem punkt sind wir noch nicht darum ist
das geradezu eine übergangsphase das hat
ja der minister noch mal glaube ich sehr
gut erklärt und
der robert der präsident vom
robert-koch-institut und jetzt kommt es
eben darauf an die schrauben
entsprechend danach zuerst hier je
nachdem wie sich die lage dann
entwickelt sehen sie da die
medienberichterstattung im moment über
dieses thema anspricht in der
medizingeschichte gern von skandalisiert
mehr erkrankung dh das sind die
krankheiten an dem ich unbedingt jeder
stirbt aber die die in den medien immer
auf kombi bearbeitet werden und die
medienberichterstattung sehe ich ähnlich
zwiespältig wie die politische aktion
auf der einen seite ist es gut wenn
medien berichten und diese sendung
gehört ja auch in diesen berichtskreis
weil aufklärung passiert auf der anderen
seite befeuert das natürlich auch die
angst die sorge die panik ein weiterer
aspekt wir haben es ja schon
angesprochen die ökonomischen gefahren
wenn wir jetzt mal auf unsere
unternehmen gucken oder auf unsere
wirtschaft
das ganze passierte zu einem denkbar
schlechten zeitpunkt
es gibt eine konjunkturabschwächung es
gibt probleme auf den internationalen
märkten wegen des von trump zaun
gebrochenen handelskriegs praxis zum
beispiel so eine weitere frage das heißt
dass verschärft jetzt auch das problem
der deutschen wirtschaft ja ich meine so
eine epidemie und vielleicht dann
beginnende pandemie also die wirtschaft
ist an der stelle nicht dass das
prioritäre sind die menschen die es zu
schützen gilt das ist keine frage aber
wir sind in dieses jahr schon merklich
schlecht eingestiegen
das kommt von der außenwirtschaft und
und china ist sozusagen im dreh und
angelpunkt auch dieser schwäche was
gestern noch eine stärke war dass wir
die deutsche wirtschaft viele andere
länder auch mit china im handel treten
produktionsketten aufgebaut haben wird
dann natürlich in so einer situation
auch zu einer schwäche wenn es zu einer
weiteren schwächung neben den anderen
elementen die sie herr keller
angesprochen haben
führt und umgekehrt sage ich aber auch
diversifizierung also keine
flaschenhälse schaffen
die deutsche wirtschaft der vorwurf wird
häufig auch erhoben sei zu abhängig von
china und wir sind nicht stärker
abhängig als zum beispiel in der
größenordnung wie von frankreich wie von
den usa aber eben in dieser
größenordnung also diversifizierung
verschiedenen bezugsquellen damit das
wirtschaftsleben weiterlaufen kann damit
auch dann die versorgung dann auch mit
medizinischen produkten weiterlaufen
darf ich mal kurz ein haken es hat in
der tat ja heute genau in diese richtung
eine verbalattacke gegeben vom
französischen wirtschaftsminister
brüderle mehr der gesagt hat jetzt zeigt
sich an diesem der ausbreitung des
corona virus wie leichtsinnig es war
dass wir uns die solche abhängigkeit
gegenüber china gebracht haben
dahinter steckt mutmaßlich auch der
vorwurf den internationalen unternehmen
ging es vor allen dingen um
kostensenkungen die gehen dorthin wo es
eben am günstigsten ist man die kosten
senken kann
und wenn das dann ein land ist in dem so
etwas passiert was also teile der
politik teile der ökonomie des
stabilisiert dann sehen wir das problem
dass wir mit unseren globalen
lieferketten irgendwie eine falsche
strategie eingeschlagen haben was sagen
sie zu dem vorwurf
also wenn die medizinischen experten mir
sagen dass eine solche krankheit nur in
china auftreten kann und nicht irgendwo
anders ja dann kann ich diese
argumentation noch etwas abgewinnen es
war der vorwurf einer zu kassieren wenn
ja also die deutsche wirtschaft und den
meisten deutschen unternehmen sind nicht
nur abhängig von china es gibt eine
wechselseitige abhängigkeit von ganz
vielen ländern ja wir leben in der
globalisierung wenn eine pandemie kommt
die viele länder erfasst dann sind wir
in besonderer weise erfasst es ist nicht
eine einseitige abhängigkeit von china
wir haben länder wie mexiko die sind zu
70 80 prozent abhängig in ihrem
außenhandel von den vereinigten staaten
deutschland andere
europäische länder sind von keinem land
in diesem maße abhängig
die schwäche und die krankheit und die
reaktionen wie wie china damit
umgegangen ist hat eine wirtschaftliche
konsequenz unsere handelskammern haben
heute eine pressekonferenz gemacht zu
den wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen auf
die deutschen unternehmen in china und
diese auswirkung sind gravierend ja aber
wir haben zum glück andere länder andere
bezugsquellen jetzt kommt aber die
krankheit zu uns jetzt merken wir auch
wir müssen reagieren und auch das wird
konsequenzen haben und die werden noch
stärker sein als die wenn es denn so
kommt aber das sind wir angewiesen auf
die frage wie breitet sich das aus und
wie können oder müssen wir behördlich
reagieren oder auch in den betrieben
dass die menschen und das machen die
unternehmen heute schon dass sie
versuchen menschen nicht in gebiete zu
schicken wo viele menschen vom gros ging
ja um den in den warenverkehr jetzt auch
also importwaren die möglicherweise
demnächst nicht mehr eintreffen
autoteile pharmazeutische produkte das
war allerdings schon vor dem gronauer
wieder so da gab es engpässe da ist zu
wenig auf den markt hier angekommen weil
es eben zu weit diversifiziert war in
bei den verschiedenen hersteller merkten
aber die frage ist ja wenn wir jetzt da
nicht schlafen und da haben sie in
norditalien haben sie
automobilzulieferer
jetzt trifft genau das gleiche
dass wir jetzt sagen also möglicherweise
müssen wir es doch überlegen dass wir
uns nicht nur von einem land zu abhängig
machen gerade in dem bereich automobil
und gesundheitsindustrie
also wir beziehen aus china für die
industrie zehn prozent von vorleistungen
so das halte ich nicht für übertrieben
viel dass wir nicht wenn in china die
vorleistung nicht geliefert werden
können
aus den genannten gründen dass wir es
aus anderen ländern beziehen natürlich
gibt es immer wieder
knackpunkte und und wege gabelungen die
besonders delikat sind und deshalb
müssen wir alles tun also die beste
wirtschaftspolitik im moment ist alles
zu unternehmen diese ausbreitung des
virus zu verhindern und und nicht etwa
zu sagen jetzt müssen wir mal schauen
dass wir unsere abhängigkeit von china
reduzieren
ich glaube nicht dass des corona virus
jetzt hier eine singuläre und einmalige
situation in der wirtschaft verursacht
hat wenn man sich anguckt wie die
wirtschaftlichen folgen von cholera
epidemie diskutiert worden sind dann hat
man durchaus ähnliche muster das heißt
ganz ohne den bezug zu china und die
globalisierung die wir heute haben haben
wir auch schon in früheren zeiten die
debatte bei und nach epidemien gehabt
was denn die wirtschaftlichen folgen
sind und was sie waren was das gekostet
hat also auch das halte ich für
vielleicht im moment ja nicht
überdramatisiert aber im langen gang der
geschichte wird sich auch das wieder
beruhigen
heute ist der bundesgesundheitsminister
gefragt worden wie es denn um diese
sogenannt pandemiepläne steht dir was
passiert wenn es wirklich zu einer
pandemie kommt also epidemie ist ja eine
ganz scharfe hatte infektion allerdings
sie räumlich und zeitlich begrenzte
pandemie in einem ganz großen raum also
eine infektion über ganze länder über
ganzen regionen hinweg
und dann hat er geantwortet und vor
allem die frage noch zu diesen
pandemieplänen was man gelernt hat aus
den früheren erfahrungen mit der saas
epidemie zum beispiel und dann sagte ich
entspannen ja man hätte die auch
angepasst mit diesen erfahrungen was er
seine lehre die ja jetzt schon ziehen
würde sei aber dass man die glaube
glaubt er zu wenig geübt hätte also die
ganzen szenarien
das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich zu spät da
mit dem üben anzufangen was steckt denn
in diesen pandemieplänen drin war es ein
um die presse ist da niedergelegt wie
wird der staat und wir müssen auch die
menschen dann reagieren also da geht es
natürlich hauptsächlich die
krankenhäuser zu befähigen diesen
massiven zuwachs an patienten gut und
schnell behandeln zu können und das ist
natürlich auch sehr spezifischer jedes
krankenhaus
da wird geschaut so zu sagen wo gibt es
eine innere welche ressourcen können
sagen umgeschaltet werden damit dann
eben diese patienten isoliert und
entsprechend in den sich medizinisch
behandelt werden können also das so wie
der minister also auch gesagt hat ist
natürlich einmal von bundesland zu
bundesland unterschiedlich und aufgrund
unserer föderalen struktur die
vernetzung sozusagen zentral nach berlin
dann eben zum teil schwierig wenn es
denn wirklich zu sehr kritischen
situation kommt diese situation gab es
noch nicht insofern bin ich da auch
etwas über fragt und aber auch gespannt
wie das denn sein wird wenn es mal
soweit ist wenn denn eine epidemie oder
pandemie ausgebrochen ist was macht man
dann eigentlich am besten um diesen
ausbruch einzudämmen
sie benutzen dieses wort glaube ich
nicht so sagen höchstens noch
verlangsamen wie kann man dann diesen
erreger und die von dem erreger befallen
am besten isolieren wenn das in auf ganz
breiter front plötzlich passiert geht
nicht so viele infizierte haben es geht
um die minderung der folgen und da gibt
es natürlich für jedes virus
unterschiedliche mittel beider influenza
hätten wir ein impfstoff hier beim
corona virus arbeiten wir letztendlich
an einem impfstoff die dann auch zur
verfügung stehen werden und diese
maßnahmen kommen dann natürlich in so
eine pandemie reihen die sich weiter
fortsetzen wird wir hätten jetzt ein
medikament zur verfügung im nächsten
tagen wird das natürlich ein
entscheidendes mittel um diese pandemie
sozusagen zurückzudrängen
ja da hoffen wir 21 habe ich gehört dass
er das betrifft die neuen entwicklungen
gibt aber auch medikamente die bereits
am markt sind die gerade in china
getestet werden und das wäre natürlich
eine elegante lösung um schwere verläufe
denn zu vermeiden dann kommen wir wieder
auf dieses problem viele dieser
medikamente wenn ich mir in deutschland
hergestellt es gibt natürlich einen
massiven bedarf nach diesen medikamenten
in den anderen ländern auch und dann ist
die frage wie gut ist deutschland
vorbereitet ist das sozusagen in den
plänen abgebildet das ist die vielleicht
hilft dieser impfstoff da ist ja auch
klar
der impfstoff selber sozusagen würde
wahrscheinlich dass nächstes jahr
fördern prophylaktisch das medikament
das jetzt hier im raum steht ein als
malaria medikament oder ein medikament
crestor iv therapie eingesetzt wurde
das könnte dann eben sofort eingesetzt
weil diese medikamente zu überlassen
hilft das wenn sagen jetzt eigentlich
auch nicht der impfstoff den wir
brauchen für diese neues medikament
genau wir warten dort auf die klinischen
daten aus china die werden in den
nächsten tagen vorliegen und dann kann
man entscheiden hilft das und die muss
es eingesetzt werden
und das wäre natürlich hervorragend um
zu vermeiden dass die intensivstation
die rettungsstellen mit schwerkranken
überlastet werden das thema quarantäne
hat er hat auch eine rolle gespielt sind
im moment 400 menschen etwa in
quarantäne stand heute abend das ist ja
eine ganz wichtige maßnahme jetzt habe
ich gehört bei einem von einem kollegen
oder abend bei einem schaltgespräch in
der heute sendung die gesundheitsämter
die das eigentlich kontrollieren müssten
können das gar nicht so richtig
kontrollieren weil gerade im kreis
heinsberg dort wo viele jetzt in der
hessischen rhön quarantäne sind die
leben weit auseinander iv lässt sich
kaum kontrollieren andererseits ist es
ja eine verpflichtende maßnahme dass er
keine freiwillige leistung lässt sich so
etwas dann auch wirklich durchsetzen
wenn das noch in viel größerem maße
stattfindet also wenn die menschen nicht
mit arbeiten lässt sich das nicht
durchsetzen da ist man ganz ganz
intensiv darauf hat der minister heute
auch mehrfach hingewiesen
man ist natürlich auf die auf die
mitarbeit auf die einsicht auf das
wollen der bevölkerung angewiesen
ich glaube allerdings dass es im moment
sehr groß ist weil die unruhe über
dieses über diese neue krankheit doch
wirklich sehr sehr groß ist jetzt mal
ganz unabhängig davon ob sie jetzt sehr
gefährlich mittel gefährlich oder gar
nicht so sehr gefährlich ist es ist eine
neue krankheit und alle neuen dinge
beunruhigen die menschen
und deswegen ist es natürlich auch
richtig dass die politik die breitest
möglichen informationen gibt und
natürlich auch signalisiert dass sie da
wachsam ist und das menschenmögliche tun
ich die die frage ob sich das am ende
eindämmen lässt glaube ich wirklich
hängt davon ab ob die bevölkerung der
bereit ist mit zu arbeiten es gibt ja
jetzt auch ganz neue vorschläge die die
politik heute gemacht hat also zum
beispiel reisende die aus dem ausland
kommen sollen ja wenn sie aus den zügen
steigen aus den bussen steigen
freiwillig eine sogenannte
habe ich den namen vergessen also eine
karte aufsteiger karte ganz genau
ausfüllen damit man weiß woher sind die
menschen eigentlich gekommen auch das
ist ja freiwillig und wenn die leute das
nicht tun dann dann tun sie es nicht
aber auch da glaube ich es gibt da im
moment eine sehr hohe einsicht und
bereitschaft auch unangenehme dinge auf
sich zu nehmen um dazu beizutragen dass
eben diese krankheit sich nicht
ausbreitet jetzt diese angst vor einer
möglichen infizierung dann tatsächlich
auch dieses verhalten frei zu sagen also
ich sehe jetzt ein
wir haben gerade gehört keine
ansammlungen keine massenveranstaltungen
vielleicht nicht in der kneipe zu gehen
in nächster zeit vor allem wenn man
einander gegend wohnt wo ist diese
infizierung gibt wie ist das eigentlich
dass man dann da ist ja die mitarbeit
die einsichtsfähigkeit auch erfordert
vielleicht ist das naiv von mir aber ich
setze da wirklich auf aufklärung und
vernunft und ich glaube daran und man
hat bei der aids beim ausbruch von aids
in der brd oder bei der ausbreitung von
aids in der brd damals gesehen
1980 er jahre in den 1980 er jahren dass
da auch zwei positionen eigentlich
gegeneinander standen auf der einen
seite hardliner die sagten man muss die
infizierten kazan ihren in quarantäne
stellen und nur so bekommt man es im
griff und auf der anderen seite
politikerinnen und politiker die sachen
aufklärung aufklärung aufklärung und bei
der aids epidemie bei der ausbreitung
hat die aufklärung letztendlich dazu
geführt dass die infizierten zahlen
sanken
und ich glaube wie gesagt mag naiv sein
aber ich glaube daran dass das auch hier
der fall sein wird wann wären denn
abrechnung statt und wenn die massive
mobilitäts beschränkungen nötig also zum
beispiel bei der einreise ins land oder
auch bei der ausreise dass auch die
europäischen länder untereinander sagen
wir müssen den reiseverkehr weitgehend
einstellen um eben die ausbreitung nicht
noch mehr zu stimulieren ich glaube dazu
kann es nicht kommen also ich fand das
sehr sehr gut wie will die maßnahmen
jetzt getroffen wurden sind genau die
richtigen irgendwann geben die
ressourcen das aber nicht mehr her und
dann sind wir genau auf die mitarbeit
der menschen angewiesen um eben diese
schnelle ausbreitung zu verhindern
man wird dann wenn es so zu sagen das
kann relativ schnell gehen in den
nächsten tagen dass es eben hundert oder
tausend erkrankte gibt eben genau diesen
wechsel machen dass man ihm nicht mehr
die einzelfälle nachverfolgt nicht mehr
sozusagen quarantänemaßnahmen weil es
die ressourcen nicht hergeben
und dann geht ihnen der wechsel daran
dass man eben ältere personen und
geschwächte sie dauer fokussiert und die
gut behandelt und darum macht es denn
auch keinen sinn mehr die grenzen zu
schließen ist dass wir ein so massiver
einschnitte die infrastruktur die
versorgung mit medikamenten und
nahrungsmitteln denn dann hätten wir
quasi ein zweites johann und das wollen
wir vermeiden
das gilt auch für die abriegelung von
städten das gilt auch für die abhebung
von stetten natürlich also dass wir
nicht die maßnahmen die hier ziel führen
werden bei uns in europa es gibt ja
jetzt schon mobilitäts beschränkungen
auch wenn es doch gar keine
administrativen massnahmen dazu gibt er
die lufthansa hat ihre flüge nach
ostasien nicht nur nach china jetzt
weitgehend eingestellt oder will sie
einstellen oder nur noch bedarf und
steckt es ja kaum noch bedarf das
bedeutet die aber gerade für die
unternehmen die dort aktiv sind sind
nicht da unternehmen die in corona virus
gebieten aktiv sind ja auch eine
empfindliche schädigung ihres geschäftes
oder ja aber für die unternehmen steht
die fürsorgepflicht ihre
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter an
erster stelle also das ist auch aus
vielen unternehmen mittlerweile und wir
haben die erfahrung leider jetzt in
china machen müssen
und da haben die behörden ja sehr
regulativ eingegriffen also bis hin dass
gastwirtschaften nicht öffnen und dann
durften auch nicht lesen mussten den ist
gesamte umsatz weggebrochen viele
dienstleistung wo menschen
zusammenkommen also wenn es hoffentlich
nicht so weit kommen muss heißt es was
muss anderes passieren damit die
ausbreitung dieser krankheit
nicht in dem maße erfolgt wie es
ansonsten wäre und unternehmen machen
das heute auch natürlich freiwillig weil
sie die fürsorgepflicht für ihre
mitarbeiter empfinden und machen
videokonferenzen statt die nächste
geschäftsreise machen regelungen zu home
office oder bereiten sich stark darauf
vor wir sind dein engen austausch mit
dem bundeswirtschaftsministerium
dass das auch eine hotline eingerichtet
wird wenn solche fragen gestellt werden
haftungsfragen wenn man aufgrund dieser
dann höheren gewalt wenn es dann so
eingeschätzt wird auch in
haftungsprobleme kommt ein vertrag die
bestimmungen nicht nicht eine
verpflichtung nicht einhalten kann
also das wird jetzt unternommen da wird
sich gewappnet man musste auch erst
abwarten
kommt diese krankheit weil es ist dann
am ende nicht umsonst was ist dann
hoffentlich alle mühe wert stimmt es
dass das ein oder andere
mittelständische unternehmen das
besonders in china aktiv ist jetzt
richtig in schwierigkeiten kommt große
probleme hat ja
dort durften dann in der provinz hudeida
woran die hauptstadt ist die mitarbeiter
mitarbeiter gar nicht kommen
in die in die betriebe und in anderen
provinzen wurde das teilweise in
abgeschwächter form aber eben auch
praktiziert und dann gibt's
personalengpässe dann gibt es
lieferprobleme
dann gibt's finanzierungsengpässe kosten
laufen weiter und es gibt keine
produktion kein dienst keine einnahmen
ja und wir haben unternehmen die das hat
natürlich auf der kippe sind oder
vielleicht auch schon darüber hinaus das
ist keine frage
wirtschaftlich kostet das was es gibt ja
nicht nur deutsche und deutsche firmen
die in china in asien tätig sind leben
wir auch viele asiaten in deutschland
studenten vertreter von unternehmen
wissenschaftler die sich vorübergehend
hier aufhalten da haben jetzt einige
folgen in den großstädten ganz
unangenehme erfahrungen gemacht so sind
nämlich lackierten angegriffen worden
weil man angenommen hat nur weil jemand
asiatisch aussieht ist er möglicherweise
träger des corona virus selbst wenn
diese leute schon vielleicht seit jahren
gar nicht mehr zu hause waren
ist das auch eine erfahrung die man
immer wieder machten solchen aus
extremsituationen bei infektionen die
von weither kommen dass man da plötzlich
sich dann entschuldige sucht ja man
sucht die schuld immer bei mandern das
ist nicht nur bei solchen so aber eben
auch bei solchen so und anderes aussehen
die ferne eine krankheit die auch noch
mit einem land einer region assoziiert
wird in der ganzen berichterstattung
wird dann auf die person zurückgeführt
und diese person die von außen kommt
trägt ein zeichen dass gar kein
krankheitszeichen ist nämlich ein
anderes aussehen in sich und schon wird
die kopplung gemacht im kopf der leute
anderes aussehen region krankheit dieser
mensch ist potenziell erkrankt also
halte ich mich davon fern und so gut das
ist mit dem nicht die hände schütteln
das müssen wir uns ja auch quasi
abgewöhnen weil schon das schütteln der
hand ja eigentlich ein zeichen der
freundschaft ist und schon wenn wir
darüber reden dass wir das lassen reden
wäre ja von dass wir etwas was wir
eingeübt haben um einander freundlich zu
begegnen seien lassen das ist eine ganz
kleine stufe aber die nächste stufe ist
dann sich von einer bestimmten gruppe
von personen fernhalten nicht dass das
jemand dreht aber das passiert im kopf
der menschen und krankheit kommt von
außen in der idee also ist das außen das
was man meiden muss
es komme jetzt ja auch wieder
situationen das diesen patienten in
nordrhein westfalen wo die frau
kindergärtnerin ist sehr gut also dass
ist da so eine lokal jedenfalls so eine
kampagne gab
warum seid ihr da hingegangen zu dieser
fasnachtsveranstaltung das macht man
doch dann auch nicht also auch da die
suche nach einem schuldigen nach einem
der das quasi verursacht hat also das
sind wirklich ganz diffizile
psychologische prozesse die sich da
abspielen und da muss man glaube ich
sehr sehr aufpassen und glaube ich
glaube weil
rohner virus fall im landkreis starnberg
bei menschen ja auch so dass die
mitarbeiter dieses cabrio dachhersteller
es da auch regelrecht diskriminiert
worden sind also die dann ja erkrankt
worden sind durch den besuch einer
chinesischen kollegen aus wo hahn die da
auch stigmatisiert wurden genommen genau
der gleiche mechanismus
es ist eine implizite schuldfrage ein
impliziter schuldvorwurf und der wird
dann ja immer größer immer immer größer
noch mal der punkt sozusagen dieser
kulturelle hintergrund tradition
händeschütteln das ist ganz wichtig in
solchen ausbrüchen das habe ich in
afrika gesehen bewegen da wird wieder
der ebola krise
darauf muss man eingehen das sind ganz
wichtige punkte die für die übertragung
sozusagen notwendig sind und das muss
man letztendlich dann auch mit solchen
kollegen angehen damit die leute das
annehmen das kann nicht verordnet werden
weil die leute verstehen das zum teil
nicht und chinas anders als deutschland
frankreich es anders als deutschland und
da muss man dann auch spezifische
maßnahmen ergreifen damit das auch
effektiv umgesetzt werden kann
wenn wir schon mal eine erste lehre aus
der ausbeutung des kroner virus ziehen
man hat ja quasi durch die
berichterstattung als das in china
ausbrach und hier noch gar nichts
passiert war ja quasi in echtzeit diesen
erreger verfolgen können wie er sich von
china aus richtung usa australien dass
man glaube die ersten adressaten bis
nach europa dann ausgebreitet hat also
wir sehenden auges quasi sehen wir ein
erreger auf uns zukommt früher hat man
eine epidemie erst bemerkt wenn sie
wirklich ausgebrochen waren halt und
stelle hätte man da vielleicht schon bei
wenn tief was anders machen sollen als
es nach einer gefühlten erinnerung ja
einige tage gedauert hat oder vielleicht
sogar eine woche bis das dann in anderen
ländern auftauchen also alles das was
man machen konnte wurde gemacht
zumindestens in deutschland und auch in
vielen vielen anderen ländern in der
region die haben erkrankungen sehr früh
nachweisen können und somit eine
schnelle ausbreitung verhindern können
das modell ist ehrlich nicht gestoppt
werden aber letztendlich war die welt
sozusagen sehr sehr gut darauf
vorbereitet ich habe auch schon mal
gesagt vor 30 jahren wäre vielleicht der
regel gar nicht entdeckt worden oder
sehr spät erst entdeckt worden
also da hat sich wirklich sehr viel
getan und gerade diese verfolgung in
echtzeit hat dazu beigetragen ganz
schnell
richtigen maßnahmen zu ergreifen was
macht eigentlich so ein erreger hat der
mal irgendwann mal keine lust mehr und
verschwindet dann wieder wie muss man
sich das vorstellen der geh da ganz
eigene wege
jetzt mal unabhängig von der bekämpfung
dass man versucht man kann ihn ja kaum
noch eindämmen man kann höchstens
versuchen zu verlangsamen wie es heißt
ist ja irgendwann mal der zenit
überschritten wie wie ist die
entwicklung eigentlich solche eines
solchen eines solchen virus ist ein
virus ist ein virus ist einfach da ist
will ja nichts es gibt ja nicht das
heißt das kommt ganz auf die kontakte an
wie sozusagen der schlüssel in das
schloss passt und das eigentlich mit dem
virus zusammen sondern wie wir uns
fortbewegen was wir essen mit wem oder
wie wir kommunizieren das sind
letztendlich die faktoren
insofern hängt das gar nicht vom virus
ab sondern wie wir uns verhalten wie der
mensch zu verhält das jetzt dass
letztendlich die ursachen für diese
ganzen ausbrüchen mit denen wir zu tun
haben wir durch dringend barrieren die
es früher gab in den urwäldern zu tieren
und das führt zu diesen ausbrüchen und
andersherum
wie gut dass große zurückdrängen der
großen kranken der solchen züge die
durch europa gezogen sind ist nicht
durch medizinische technik gelungen
sondern dadurch dass wir
hygienemaßnahmen eingeführt haben städte
hygienisch ausgestattet haben und damit
verhalten verändert haben also im grunde
hat die kultur den umgang mit solchen
verändert nicht nur die solchen natur
hat sich verändert
diese pressekonferenz wurde von seehofer
und sparen sie dient der ja auch der
bekanntgabe eines dass ein krisenstab
jetzt gebildet worden ist auf der
obersten politischen ebene das
robert-koch-institut dass hierfür die
seuchenbekämpfung in deutschland oberste
stelle zuständig ist wird ab morgen ein
tägliches pressebriefing veranstalten
schon ein hinweis darauf wie ernst die
situation ist wir haben ja durch unsere
föderale struktur unterschiedliche
zuständigkeiten auf der bundes auf der
länder auf der kommunalebene
da achtet man ja sonst auch eifersüchtig
darauf dass jeder so seine zuständigkeit
behält ist dieses system jetzt bei der
bekämpfung des corona virus vielleicht
sogar sehr positiv zu sehen oder könnte
es sein das ist dann auch die schwächen
dieses systems zeigen
ja ich habe ja am anfang schon gesagt
ich glaube dieses föderales system hat
also ich finde sowieso dass es viele
sehr viele schwächen hat es wirkt sich
dann als schwach erweisen wenn dieses
virus sich wirklich nur über ganz
deutschland ausgebreitet hat also über
alle bundesländer und wenn dann
maßnahmen koordiniert werden müssen dann
werden wir sehen ob das dann durch
diesen eben durch den bundesweiten
krisenstab dann gelingt also ob es dann
wirklich gelingt die nationalen
kompetenzen außer kraft zu setzen und
dieses durchgriffsrecht was ja besteht
dann auch wirklich dann auch wirklich
anzuwenden da es gibt in der verfassung
auch so etwas wie notstandsmaßnahmen das
ist ja auch verfassungsrechtlich
verbriefte in einer situation wo es dann
wirklich ganz schwierig wird
ja wobei also ich finde die dass die
tatsache dass er zurzeit ein
großaufgebot an politischer intervention
macht demonstriert wird passt nicht so
ganz hundertprozentig zu dem was
inhaltlich gesagt wird wie gefährlich
eigentlich die krankheit ist also diesen
diese diskrepanz habe ich wirklich heute
ganz ganz stark empfunden
vielleicht bin ich da auch zu locker
jetzt im umgang mit dieser krankheit
aber ich sehe eigentlich im moment nicht
das sozusagen die gesamte bundesdeutsche
gesundheits macht sich auf dieses virus
stürzen müsste es ist glaube ich sehr
viel symbolik dabei die politik versucht
im moment auch zu demonstrieren dass sie
handlungsfähig ist ein junger
gesundheitsminister sparen hat jetzt
auch die möglichkeit sich zu profilieren
ich meine das jetzt gar nicht abwertend
sondern das ist einfach so
und das ist für ihn auch wichtig im
moment in dem zustand in dem die union
ist an das hat er eine bühne wo er sich
einfach gut präsentieren kann das hat er
heute auch gut gemacht und ich glaube
solche sachen spielen auch in diese
corona krise mit rein
es geht ja auch um die tests und man
eben herausfinden kann ob jemand
erkrankt ist das sollen jetzt alle
krankenkassen auch bezahlen haben wir
genügend kapazitäten das testen
die gar kein problem vor wie man
mittlerweile auch kommerzielle teste sie
sind breit verfügbar in ganz deutschland
also bei seinen tests kapazitäten müssen
uns wirklich keine sorgen macht das
schon mal eine gute nachricht politische
intervention war glatt ein stichwort
herr dreyer
fühlen sie sich in dieser situation von
der politik also was die anliegen der
wirtschaft angeht genügend unterstützt
offenes ohr für die anliegen der
wirtschaft die ja eben auch die
konsequenzen tragen das ja wir haben
hier bei ausbruch des virus in china
glaube ich auch treffen gehabt mit dem
auswärtigen amt und dem
bundeswirtschaftsministerium da geht es
natürlich um die wirtschaftlichen
konsequenzen die die verbindung zwischen
den reisewarnungen hinweisen des
auswärtigen amts nach china und welche
folgen das hat die frage jetzt der
infizierung hier nach europa von mehr
menschen als zuvor und und und dann der
zusammen des zusammenspiels der behörden
mit mit den betrieben wir haben
dreieinhalb millionen betrieben in
deutschland wir haben ein netzwerk an
beratenden institutionen die industrie
und handelskammern gehören dazu jetzt
werden die leitfäden und schaaf gestellt
und und beratungsstruktur eingerichtet
man muss sich drauf verlassen wie
eingeschätzt wird wie ein solches virus
was wir noch nicht erlebt haben also saß
da waren 5000 menschen betroffen in
china sind jetzt schon 80.000 allein in
china
also das ist eine andere dimension wie
so ein virus dann hier eingetragen wird
wie es sich ausbreitet um dann maßnahmen
anzugehen und die müssen natürlich dann
auch situationsgerecht sein und und
vielleicht nicht zu spät reagieren um
dann in dieser drastische drastischen
maßnahmen in china reagiert wurde dann
mit erheblichen wirtschaftlichen
konsequenzen und einbussen für für die
lebensumstände der menschen gut dann
werden wir das jetzt erstmal weiter
beobachten
ich bedanke mich wie sich das
weiterentwickelt und
frage mich dass sie da waren die wir
zuschauer sie haben ja gesehen wollen
wir haben auch telefonnummern das
notfalltelefon angeblichen abgeblendet
und auch eine website des der
bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung
dort können sie sich erste informationen
geben lassen
jetzt folgt phoenix der tag mit thomas
bade da geht es auch um die
pressekonferenz von sparen und seehofer
außerdem war auch heute im
innenausschuss noch eine sondersitzung
zu den rechts terroristischen morton in
hanau bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]